it was a it was a wonderful experience
and i i just enjoyed competing and
no even knowing that i wasn't going to
be able to play an actual game
i just knew that i had to just control
what i can control and that was kind of
the mindset going in
and i knew that as long as i studied the
playbook as much as humanly possible and
and just understand the offense allowed
me to perform best in practice and
treating those practices as the most
important thing
every day is vital because like those
are my games and
just being able to you know play
wherever
just be national to the team whatever
way and
was my mentality because it's all about
the team being invited to tampa bay is
an
undrafted free agent was a wonderful
opportunity learning and playing with
tom brady molchan learned how to become
a professional
it was it was awesome because i got to
i learned a lot on how to become a
professional
nothing crazy though it wasn't based off
of speeches and
it was just like just watching and
seeing how people handle themselves and
you know guys like tom brady and and a
lot of the guys in the team
the way that they handle themselves is
very professional
and it didn't take much to to learn from
that
and it's been awesome just conducting
yourself a certain way and having a
having a goal and not immersing yourself
and
and how how good you were and just
watching him be so selfless and
and with his eye on the prize has been
awesome going all the way back to april
when john
made a name for himself after being
invited to the nfl combine
i would say so and i think coming out of
that i was just
really happy with uh with how the whole
week went
and just just really enjoying it was the
biggest thing
and at times like that can become very
stressful and
some guys can lose their mental and and
lose track of the goal
and i i just really wanted to make sure
that each step
it was just a blessing and just being
there was amazing
and really enjoying everything that
that i did there and then being on the
field and you know getting the iconic 40
photo and the whole the whole nine it
was just great
and i think just making the most out of
that allowed me to
take a night a good step going forward
whether that was the draft
or like me being undrafted the combine
was an eye-opener for many teams that's
where tampa bay got a real good look at
the las vegas
for sure and tampa bay buccaneers is an
amazing organization and
they don't discriminate based on if
you're drafted or undrafted
and they they put me in a position to
show what i have
and i was able to to do that and
i can't thank them enough they've been
they everything they've said to me uh
after the job up to this point has been
identical
and they they've really given me the
ability
to perform and and the ability to show
myself
and i cannot thank them enough because
um
who knows if what would have happened if
i went to anywhere else and
it was it was just a perfect place very
nice let me ask you now going back to
the
faith lutheran days you know you got
mike sanford now coaching the
crusaders that you knew that but um so
you have the former unlv coach now
coaching your
old high school uh just going back to
faith lutheran and i didn't realize this
though but you kind of
you were more of a basketball guy than a
football guy right
yeah at the start i i went to faith i
was super pumped up and i wanted to play
basketball got to
get to play varsity as a freshman and
i was also very big with club basketball
and just the competitive atmosphere
what was the best part did how did faith
lutheran prepare you for them boise and
now the nfl if
or or did it yeah they failed and for
sure prepared me
in many ways first thing in the
classroom just
just making sure that i knew that that
was the most important thing going into
college
was that i wanted to get my degree and
you know by going through
the courses that they lutheran allowed
me to you know
learn things that i don't think i would
have learned at other places and and
kind of build
a enjoyment for finance in some sort of
way
and i got to take some extra business
classes and that kind of like stirred up
my interest
and that's why i ended up going to boise
state and getting my finance degree
and as far as athletics go i would say
just in my time to be able to compete
through
basketball even track and field my final
year in football
i i was able to compete and i was taught
very many lessons
not only from coach walter but also
vernon fox and
and coach nate knight and i i cherish
those moments because they
at the end of the day all those coaches
put me in a position to
to be as competitive as i could be and
to be
ready for college now how cool is this
no one in a million years would have
guessed this three four five years ago
you will be playing nfl football in
allegiant stadium against the las vegas
raiders
later on this season is that like so
wild
yeah it's it's it's been an awesome
journey even
from high school all the way here it's
uh it's it's something that
i dreamed of but it was never something
that i
rushed to do and it was just making sure
that i just
took care of the task ahead of me and
really enjoying the moment
allowed me to make the most out of each
experience and
and i'm super excited for that and i
cannot wait
but i think just enjoying each day has
been most valuable to me
you'll get it's funny how you'll get to
come back here to vegas
and watch you know from the sidelines uh
with your [ __ ]
now unfortunately no fans unfortunately
but but here in las vegas an nfl
franchise is that hard to believe when
you were
say a freshman in high school would you
ever imagine that
no and it's amazing and that's why i
love vegas because
the the community welcomes sports
and it's it's amazing to see what we've
done not only with the golden knights
but the aviators and
i'm excited to see the las vegas
community wrap their
their hands around and get excited for
some raider football
i think they'll do a great job and i
think it'll be a great place to play so
i'm excited